[موسيقى]
اكبر المشاكل اللي بتلاقينا هي المشاكل
بتاعه
الديمومه والاستمراريه والسدامه حقت
الانتاج
واسباب كثيره منها القطع الجائر للشجار
او القطعه المقصود الاشجار
والهجره الحاصله في في مناطق الانتاج من
قبل
المزارعين السبب الاساسي في قطع الاشجار
هو يعني او السببين الاساسيات اللي بيعدوا
الى قطع الاشجار هم الاسعار المدنيه
عالميا في بعض المواسم بتضغط
التجاره والمصدرين ومن ثم
المنتجين في الازعار مما تجبرن لانه يمشوا
لبدائل اخرى يعني غير الثمار العربي
[موسيقى]
يتم تهريبه بكميات كبيره جدا عليها 45 الف
طن سنويا ودي نسبه كبيره جدا يعني المزارع
ممكن يكون اكثر شخص بيتاثر في في الامر ده
لانه المزارع تعبان
وبيزرعوا وفي النهايه بيلقى انه القيمه
بتاعه الصمغ قلت او نقصت من القيمه
الحقيقيه بسبب التهريب